and finally new rule now that
republicans have begun
welcoming q anon into the political
mainstream
it's time americans learn what it is q
anon is a growing movement within the
republican party that believes the world
is being run behind the scenes by a
small group of elitist liberals and
hollywood celebrities
who are both satan worshipers and
pedophiles
who eat babies and wear red shoes to
signal their membership
in this group a group that includes
hillary clinton
tom hanks ellen the pope and every
president since reagan
and that there are two heroes who will
put a stop to this
president donald trump and q himself
the anonymous leader who founded cue
anon with one overarching theme
that you're being lied to and everything
you think you know
is really the opposite what you're
seeing in what you're
reading is not what's happening
that's why it makes sense within q anon
that trump who most americans see as a
sex
creep who walks in on half-dressed
beauty pageant contestants and
tells underage girls he'll be dating
them in 10 years
actually is the christian savior who
will destroy these sex fiends
it is also why it makes perfect sense
that i
libertine atheist pot-smoking
trump-hating bill maher
mq i am which i revealed on this show
two years ago which is why it is true
i am q you don't believe me just ask
yourself
is there any non-evidence
well it's two years later and i'm gonna
tell you again
i am you i am and true q followers know
it's the truth
because it makes the least sense think
people
that's all i'm saying take what you
thought flip it and then assume the
opposite of the opposite of what you
know is not true
then and only then are you thinking like
a true q anon
and if you need any more proof that i am
q
just remember that after i was revealed
as q
in 2018 this old picture came out of me
wearing red shoes
which of course i wore back then for the
same reason trump acted like a
disgusting pervert for the last 30 years
because i knew this day would come or i
would have to prove that i
am what i'm not and don't be intimidated
by the so-called
same people who say we're stupid and
gullible and lonely aimless losers
oh you can make fun of us all you want
but the joke is on you
because q anon is now so mainstream
that 71 republicans running for office
this year have espoused humanon beliefs
that's more republicans than believe in
evolution or vegetables
and we're very proud that one of our
candidates marjorie taylor green
who has been brave enough to say
publicly that hillary
likes voodoo dolls and planned
parenthood performs human sacrifices
she just won the house primary in
georgia she's going to be in congress
deal with it trump calls her a future
republican star
and she has called his presidency a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to take
this global cabal of satan worshiping
pedophiles
out exactly so laugh now if you want
but just remember that in the republican
party today's
lunatic is tomorrow's mainstream
representative
yeah sure call her crazier than a [ __ ]
house rat today
in four years you'll be calling her the
winner of the iowa caucus
same with jo ray perkins she could be
the next republican senator from
oregon and she says i stand with
president trump
i stand with cue and the team stand with
q and the team
thank you joe yes we've made great
progress in the two years since i
revealed myself i don't take all the
credit
but attention must be paid q merchandise
is now a staple of trump rallies and
president trump himself
has just this week now embraced q anon
publicly
we're blowing up [ __ ] get on the q tip
michael flynn was the national security
advisor of this country
and here he is taking the cuban on oath
where we go one we go on we're for real
[ __ ]
and what's so great now is that i can
speak to my people
my cue people with complete freedom
because the liberals just think i'm
doing a
comedy bit here such idiots
these libtards actually believe donald
trump doesn't like me
that's what they said about robert
mueller that he was trump's big enemy
when cute people know trump
feigned collusion with russia in order
to enlist mueller to join him
in exposing the ring and preventing a
coup by obama
mueller was his work wife not his enemy
last week these morons actually thought
trump was insulting me
when he tweeted about me he's totally
shot
looks terrible exhausted gaunt and weak
if there was ever a good reason for no
shutdown
check out this jerk yeah check out this
jerk he's saying check out our movement
don't be fooled just because in various
tweets and at
rallies trump has referred to me as
dopey not smart a dumb ass a lowlife
a dummy a [ __ ] a crazy maniac stupid
failing pathetic bloated third-rate
insane wacko sick
stone-cold crazy and the dumbest man on
television
that's his way of saying i'm with you
bro
so look if you're thinking of coming
over to q
or even if you think you might be
cue-ish
here are some tips for voting in this
vital upcoming election
first continue to follow blindly every
single thing i say that's most important
second don't believe election day is
really on a tuesday
it's not they tried that trick every
time
in fact this november if you really want
your voice heard
boycott the election by not voting at
all in fact
let me remind you of the key
instructions for election day that i
gave you
two years ago do not leave your house on
november 6 for
any reason even to buy vape juice
if you have a basement go there or
better get in the trunk of your car
close it and don't leave for whatever
reason just stay
in the trunk of your car until you hear
from me
stay in the trunk stay in the trunk
stay in the trunk but if you do
somehow get to the polls my fellow cue
and honors
of course go with pride and pull the
lever for the one man that can make
america great again
kanye west
you